the walls are closing in on Ron DeSantis
the Florida governor is in trouble now
you see DeSantis might have thought he
was well positioned in his political
career successful term as Governor of
Florida popular Republican with a
national profile a strong presidential
candidate for 2024 especially as federal
law enforcement officials raid and
investigate the leading Contender Donald
Trump but all of that has disappeared in
a Flash as Governor DeSantis now faces a
criminal probe himself this one not
coming from the FBI or the doj but
rather from a random sheriff in Texas we
are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected uh
activities involving the 48 migrants
from Venezuela as we understand it 48
migrants were lured I will use the word
Lord under false pretenses uh on into
into staying at a hotel for a couple of
days they were taken by airplane at a
certain point they were shuttled to an
airplane where they were flown to
Florida and then eventually flown to
Martha's Vineyard again under false
pretenses is the the information that we
have that they were promised work they
were promised the solution to several
other problems they were taken to
Martha's Vineyard from what for what we
can gather for nothing for little more
than a photo op video up and then they
were unceremoniously stranded in
Martha's Vineyard
now you might say that this random Texas
sheriff is a total goofball who has no
right or jurisdiction whatsoever to
investigate pretty much anyone and
certainly not the governor of Florida
true that's all true but Democrat
activists are celebrating the
announcement Aaron parness a Democrat
strategist with hundreds of thousands of
followers on social media boasted quote
it's official the Republican party's top
two 2024 presidential candidates Donald
Trump and Ron DeSantis are now under
criminal investigation
and while technically true
this raises an obvious question
isn't it sort of funny how that works
isn't it a little bit weird how all the
most effective Republican politicians in
the country always seem to be under
investigation now
even when there's no basis for it even
when they've never been under
investigation before until the very
moment that they seem to pose a threat
to Democrats
almost as if Democrats are wielding law
enforcement agencies under their control
to crush their political enemies
I'm beginning to think this is the new
test of whether or not a republican is
the real deal as our country descends
further and further into corruption into
the Banana Republic tactics of the
ruling party attempting to jail anyone
who seriously challenges them
I'm beginning to think this is the new
measure of a republican as the 2024
election approaches I think I am going
to have to add this to my test for
candidates there are now three criteria
that I'm going to consider as I assess
the various candidates one are they
right on the issues two do they have a
record of effectively implementing a
conservative agenda and three are the
Democrats trying to throw them in jail
as far as I am concerned the more that
the Democrats want to throw a republican
politician in prison the better that
Republican politician looks I'm Michael
Knowles is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Nikolai Serge
who says as cinnamon is a key ingredient
in the PSL and has been known to
increase testosterone Michael isn't
joking about its manliness he must be
the most virile mucho Macho Chad to
Grace the daily wire Studios to date
this is true and many people are talking
about it and frankly everybody's talking
about it and I'm I'm glad that you're
able to share that Insight with
everybody else you know it's probably
because your brain is functioning very
very well which probably means you're
getting a good night's sleep when you
want to get a great night's sleep you
got to check out Helix right now head on
over to helixsleep.com Knowles I have
had my Helix mattress for a while now
for years and I absolutely adore it
Helix has several different mattress
models to choose from they've soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus sized sleepers they also have a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else it's
crazy take that Helix sleep quiz get
matched with the perfect mattress for
you then the delivery is super duper
easy they've got a 10 year warranty you
get try it out for 100 nights risk free
they have over 12
000 5 Star reviews for a limited time
Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over to helixsleep.com
Knowles that's helixsleep.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s the top two Republican
candidates for president are under
investigation uh-huh right
well I think you're just reversing the
order of events here why do you think
that they are under investigation
do you think do you think that Donald
Trump is under investigation because he
had classified documents
just like every other president ever
do you think Trump is under
investigation because he questioned the
results of the election
just like the major Democrat candidates
for president and governor and
everywhere else for the last 20 years
he's under invest Donald Trump is under
investigation because he is the chief
political rival to Joe Biden that's it
that's the beginning and the end of it
do you think Ron DeSantis is under
investigation by this joke jokester
sheriff in Texas because he flew
migrants around the country Joe Biden's
been doing that at a much larger scale
than Rhonda santises furthermore
illegal immigration is illegal Ron
DeSantis would be well within his rights
to activate the National Guard and to
forth the people themselves back to
Mexico
no he's under investigation by this
jokester and it's being lauded by the
chattering class on the left around the
country because he is a threat to Joe
Biden
because he is a threat to the Democrats
he is he's viewed as a major threat it
will probably be a moot point because if
Donald Trump runs for president there is
a
99.999997 chance that he will win the
Republican nomination and so all the
other candidates no matter how good no
matter how effective no matter how
persuasive don't really matter as much
Trump is up 40 points in the polls right
now the race is his if he wants it but
Ron DeSantis you got to give that man
credit that guy is running a very good
not only state campaign for governor but
national campaign to put himself in a
position to be president he just
released a campaign ad this is on the
heels of the Martha's Vineyard migrant
airplane stunt that worked marvelously
take a listen to this ad
when our middle son Brandon left to go
to work he was only 21 years old and the
last words I said to him is I love you
and it twice deported illegal ran into
him and hit him so hard that he caused
Brennan's car to flow then he killed him
my child was killed by someone who
should not have been here this is what
happens when we have open borders we
were able to go and meet with Governor
DeSantis he said I want to hear your
son's story and to see the compassion in
his eyes and I saw the concern he wanted
to make sure other lies were protected
and as a governor he truly has been
upholding the ill that he took which is
to protect Floridians he not only talks
a good talk but he walks it he's been
very strong on safety he's been very
strong on Law and Order he has made our
state one of the safest states to be in
there's no greater leader than Governor
DeSantis because he didn't just listen
put action behind it
phenomenal ad I'll get to the substance
of the ad in a second but what this
proves about DeSantis as a politician is
that the man is not just a tactician but
a strategist
he's DeSantis is obviously very good at
tactics DeSantis seems to get into the
news cycle every single day somehow the
governor of Florida injects himself into
the national news cycle on every single
issue pretty much every single day
and and he's good and he's kind of
trolley and you remember when the let's
go Brandon memes started up Rhonda
Santos held a press conference in
Brandon Florida
at a car dealership or something
obviously just to be able to say we're
here in Brandon Florida
and then the people giggle about it so
he's very good at tactics
this ad obviously was not made overnight
this is a very well thought out highly
produced well-edited
intentional ad
and it's an ad
to serve as The Knockout to the Martha's
Vineyard stunt the Martha's Vineyard
stunt is the jab it's 50 little Jabs
boom boom boom yeah we're going to send
these illegal aliens to Martha's
Vineyard yeah you Libs who said you
wanted these these illegal aliens you're
going to deport them within 48 hours
you're going to send them to a military
base because you're completely full of
it and you don't actually care about the
immigrants you just want them to go to
Red States you don't actually think that
diversity is our strength you actually
think it's going to weaken your
communities that's why you're shipping
them out on a bus as quick as you
possibly can boom there's the hook
the hook is
illegal immigration killed my son and
it's hurting all sorts of Americans and
here's my story here's the real effects
of it
jab jab jab jab jab jab jab jab jab look
at this look how funny it is the lips
are such Hypocrites boom this is the
real effect of it on Americans
it means he was planning ahead
the strategy here was no it's not just
going to be a little giggle giggle look
at what Hypocrites they are because the
fact is
on this issue DeSantis and Trump and
Cruz and Abbott and every other
Republican who is a Conservative
Republican is Right illegal immigration
is seriously harming Americans it's
bringing drugs it's bringing a ton of
crime everybody who crosses that border
illegally is doing so by going into debt
with the cartels okay and the cartels
are Savage animals who are then bringing
organized crime and prostitution and
drugs and all sorts of Madness into
American communities
and to the point that that woman made in
the video any crime any even accident
that happens
at the hands of an illegal immigrant in
America is on the hands of Democrats who
encourage the illegal immigration that
man who killed that woman's son should
never have been in this country had
Democrats not broken the law and
encouraged other people to break the law
that woman's son would be alive today
that's the real effect of it to say
nothing about the people whose kids are
overdosed on fentanyl because the
Democrats broke the law and encouraged
other people to come across the border
illegally
the people who were killed by the gangs
and all the rest of it
the Republicans are right on this issue
and so you get a little bit of that the
humor the trollishness you're making the
Martha's Vineyard liberals look like
jerks but then you're punching them
you're saying no no but this is serious
though guys
okay it's thinking a couple of steps
ahead
it's still Donald Trump's race there's
no question about it but Ron DeSantis is
slowly and confidently making the case
every single day that if Trump doesn't
get it you guys should vote for me and
you're going to see other candidates
doing this as well Mike Pompeo just
announced that he's running for
president you're seeing other campaigns
go into place to say look we know that
Trump is the guy right now but if Trump
for whatever reason doesn't become the
nominee doesn't run whatever we are
ready to run there's a shadow campaign
happening behind not Trump and behind
Biden because it's looking less and less
likely that Biden is going to run as
well
if Joe Biden does not run for president
you've got a shadow campaign now of
Kamala Harris Pete bootage Elizabeth
Warren I think and Gavin Newsom who are
already running for president behind him
and no one wants to say it because we've
all got to pretend like Joe Biden can
run again because we've all got to
pretend like Joe Biden knows what day it
is and what his name is but he obviously
doesn't
and so you're seeing people get more and
more aggressive
you're actually seeing a kind of Shadow
primary play out outside of Biden and
Trump Gavin Newsom
who's probably the most aggressive and
ambitious in in running for president as
a Democrat he just challenged DeSantis
to a debate
he says Hey Governor DeSantis clearly
you're struggling distracted and busy
playing politics of people's lives since
you have only one overriding need
attention let's take this up in debate
I'll bring my hair gel you bring your
Hairspray
name the time before election day
I don't get that reference other than
both men have very nice hair but I
actually don't get really the joke these
maybe Gavin Newsom had just had a couple
of drinks at The French Laundry and was
kind of loosely tweeting but regardless
one there's no reason for DeSantis to
accept the debate I think DeSantis sort
of laughed off because because Newsom is
a failed governor
and Governor DeSantis is one of the most
effective and popular governors in the
country
but what you're seeing here is a kind of
a kind of test run hey come on debate me
debate me bro
come on I'm not worried about Joe Biden
I'm not even Donald Trump they're saying
I'm not really worried about Donald
Trump no one wants to come out and say
it
but when it comes to Trump they're
they're holding off of him because it
looks like he does want to run it looks
like he will run and he probably will
get the nomination when it comes to
Biden it's increasingly looking like he
will not run nobody wants him to run and
even if he did want to run the party
would probably tell him not to
we're in 2022 guys we haven't even hit
the midterms yet imagine how hot this is
going to be after the midterms heading
into 2023. speaking of national debates
I've got to switch gears for a little
bit here
because I've got to defend my friend
Matt Walsh Matt has been getting in big
trouble with the Media Matters and all
of the libs who are calling Matt a
racist they call us all racists because
Matt pointed out that mermaids are not
black
because Matt pointed out that mermaids
are white this is a scientific fact he
actually says that mermaids are
translucent
like all those sorts of creepy little
fish at the bottom of the sea
and this has become a big National
debate that then has gone I I think into
the realm of this absurd where one
prominent lib on social media
said that the debate is is stupid and
Matt is obviously a racist because
they're ignoring the fact that mermaids
don't even exist and I thought what are
you talking about mermaids don't exist
are you you're telling me it's 20 22. in
2022 there are still people who were
seriously arguing that mermaids do not
exist even after Christopher Columbus
saw several of them with his own eyes in
1493. even after John Cook famous sailor
John Cook
saw a mermaid
also back in the 17th century are you
kidding me
doesn't make sense
there there are many eyewitness accounts
of mermaids now I'm not saying
that mermaids definitely exist okay I'm
just saying there are many eyewitness
accounts of mermaids spanning at least
several centuries and then going Way Way
Back Into folklore I guess the point I
want to make is amid all of our modern
hubris about what all those stupid crazy
old people thought all these fantastic
delusional things I just want to point
out that for instance there is much more
scientific evidence that mermaids exist
than that the covid vaccines present
infection transmission
for sure you've got all of the the
modern
really fancy white lab coat wearing
stethoscope having modern scientists who
said that the covid vaccines will
prevent infection and transmission of
the virus and all I'm pointing out is
many more people have seen mermaids than
have seen the covid vaccine prevent
infection and transmission of the virus
there are all sorts of modern scientific
things
that are much less plausible
than
mermaids
the idea that global warming is going to
kill us all in 10 years and that was a
few years ago that people were
predicting that the idea that global
cooling was going to kill us all within
a couple of decades the idea that the
overpopulation was going to cause Mass
worldwide famines those predictions were
made by Major environmentalist groups in
1970 none of that happened
actually the world population doubled
malnutrition hit an all-time low
people became fatter than ever
much more evidence of mermaids than of
overpopulation
there's a kind there's just a modern
hubris that we have
we look in the past we say oh my gosh
those dumb old people in the I don't
know the Renaissance or the Middle Ages
or ancient times they believe the
craziest things they're big dumb idiots
because they didn't even have iPhones
like I do I'm so smart
We Believe way crazier things than they
did
there are way crazier things to believe
in than mermaids okay I'll give you an
example of one this guy Jack turban who
I've I've seen him before he's some lib
blue check he's got all sorts of weird
like gay flags and things in his uh
Twitter bio and and he's got his his
degree MD he says Jack turban MD and he
is a radical transgender activist
uh so this is what he tweets at he says
four years at Harvard five years at Yale
three more years at Harvard two years at
Stanford but Karen zero five two six
seven eight nine has some thoughts about
sex chromosomes and what he's saying
there at the end is you idiot
conservatives you seem to think that men
and women are different you don't
believe in transgenderism but I went to
Harvard you see and because I went to
Harvard I know that boys are secretly
girls or whatever
that's his argument
reminds me of Socrates Socrates famously
when arguing with an idiot he says look
neither me nor this idiot know anything
about what is really good and beautiful
but I have a little bit of an advantage
over this guy
because this guy doesn't know anything
and he thinks he knows something and I
don't know anything and I know that I
don't know anything
and it is amazing but
I have never seen somebody
with their academic degree listed in
their Twitter name You Know Jack turbin
MD or so and so PhD I've never seen
someone who lists an academic degree in
their name
who seems intelligent or wise
find me the counter example I don't mean
it just to call my opponent's idiots
right that's really not I'm just saying
if you compare
the kinds of people who list their
academic degrees and who boast about
things like I went to Harvard for this
many years and I went to Stanford and
that's why I'm so much smarter than
everybody else every time I see people
like that they seem way dumber and they
believe way crazier stuff than the
people who have any humility whatsoever
but of course this is the case this is
always the case this is not some new
phenomenon
the people who think of themselves as
super duper smart usually look like
fools and are given to Pride and hubris
and end up believing insane things and
the people who recognize that actually
we don't really know very much of
anything at all they tend to be much
wiser
and this is one of the one of the
Delights of our fallen world one of the
consolations of it is the people who
consider themselves really really smart
and wise
pretty much always look like big dumb
idiots okay
this guy Jack turbine believes that boys
are secretly girls and girls are
secretly boys and advocates
giving them all sorts of drugs and
cross-sex hormones and and bodily
genital mutilations so that little boys
look more like little girls and vice
versa and it's ghastly and it's horrible
but if you can just not think about the
suffering and pain caused by this for a
second you just think of it in a more
abstracted way it's absolutely freaking
hilarious that this dude has spent how
long he's spent
how many years in the ivy league five at
Harvard four at Harvard five at Yale
three more at Harvard something like
that it's kind of hard to see here four
years at Harvard yeah there we go nine
twelve oh then another two at Harvard so
and then and then you've got Stanford on
top of that so this guy's been in
throughout the ivy league and all the
top schools forever and he thinks that
boys can secretly be girls
it's amazing
you you out there listening very likely
did not spend all these many years A
Dozen Years in the ivy league and yet
you know that boys are not girls you are
much smarter than this man you have much
more wisdom
it's a it's a real lesson a little
humility goes a long way speaking of
LGBT
one of the most hilarious episodes that
I've ever seen come out of sports just
came out of UMass so UMass
the football team is supposed to play
Liberty University and to own
the the libs to own the Liberties really
to own the Christian conservatives UMass
has declared that their football team is
super duper gay
it says please stand by for a special
announcement
type music going on Pride day
over the football player dancing around
in a rainbow looking Club
Massachusetts versus Liberty
October 8th
3 30 yeah and he's pointing he's like
this is pride day baby
now I thought Pride day was
it wasn't Pro Pride was originally a day
then it was a week now then it was a
month but that was back in June but now
it's September and we're hearing the
pride day is going to be in October it's
just Pride all the time because LGBT is
is the kind of public religion and
public Liturgy of of the libs and so
they're forcing that on everybody else
but the UMass football team is now
they're so triggered by anyone who's
Christian or conservative like Liberty U
that in order to own the Christian
conservatives they're saying yeah yeah
you're gonna well guess what we're super
gay yeah we're not we're not even just
gay we're trans that's right yeah look
at us oh I bet you guys are so triggered
we're yeah us the UMass football team
we're actually little girls yeah that's
right yeah aren't you totally owned no
not not really at all
not really at all you are in in a vain
attempt to own liberty and the Christian
conservatives you're making yourself
look
at the very least frivolous and foolish
the time is upon us you know for another
backstage which is happening tonight 6
p.m Central 7 PM Eastern and it's about
time because there is more news than
ever to discuss if you've never seen
backstage before this is where we all
get together I get to see my daily wire
buddies Ben Matt Drew the god king
Jeremy boring for a Roundtable
discussion on the most burning topics of
the day
jokes will be cracked cigars will be
smoked Libations will be imbibed plus
we will be reuniting with our good
friend Candace Owens who is back with
exciting news and ready to tick off Libs
more than ever you definitely do not
want to miss this one tune in to join us
for backstage tonight 6 p.m Central 7
P.M Eastern at Daily wireplus.com
I'm all for trolling and owning the libs
and everything but you've got to do it
with a purpose
okay this you you saw it with DeSantis
dropping that immigration ad so he's
trolling he's sending the plane loads of
immigrants he's getting the libs to look
like Hypocrites and they but he then he
follows it up and he drops it he says
this is why it matters this is the
importance of immigration you got to
troll with a purpose
there was one time I remember there was
a conservative who was trying to to own
the libs on some college campus this was
about four or five years ago and he was
making fun of safe spaces and the guy
dressed up in a diaper and put a
pacifier or something in his mouth and
danced around and pretended to be a
little baby in a safe space he was
trying to mock the libs but he was
actually just kind of making a fool out
of himself you don't want to take it
that far I remember there was one time
in college there was a song we used to
sing in a group that I was in in college
and it was about our rival Harvard was
our rival speaking of that guy Jack
turban and this the song was sung in the
final stanza in the voice of Harvard and
the stanza went ten thousand men of
Harvard we like our College much the
girls they aren't so pretty but we sure
like to touch ourselves in the morning
when we first rise for class and when
we're fully risen and I'll let you
complete the stands of yourself and use
your imagination and so we're kind of
making fun of Harvard right in this kind
of childish way but it occurred to me
one time while we were singing it I said
wait a second we're because of how it's
phrased because we're putting it in our
own voice it sounds like we are just
saying that we do this thing that is
considered sort of disreputable are we
in an attempt to own our Rivals we're
kind of owning ourselves I think that's
what's going on here
with UMass and Liberty
they're just they're so the libs are
just so triggered at this moment
that they're really really
they're they're making very very foolish
missteps they're making themselves look
very foolish and you can tell it's not
playing very well with the public that's
why they're getting absolutely creamed
right now looking ahead into the
midterms speaking of Education really
great news I I don't think this just
happened but the news I think is just
starting to spread Kanye West has
started a school
Kanye West has started something called
The danda Academy named after his mother
donda West
who was a professor
and the school is located in Simi Valley
California and it's got a very Christian
ethos to it
the students there participate in full
School worship
as well as core classes in language arts
Math and Science then they've got the
regular stuff lunch recess enrichment
courses some films some art some choir
all sorts of things now people are
making fun of Kanye for this because
Kanye just went on a podcast and and
admitted something which is kind of
ironic for a guy who started a school he
admitted that he's never read a book
also when you said I hadn't read this
book I actually haven't read any book
reading is like eating Brussels sprouts
for me and talking is like getting the
Giorgio Baldi corn ravioli like a good
conversation is Mike Mike Howe that
invented the rip saw with his brother uh
Jeff Howe
um
was saying that when his mom texts him
like long paragraphs he reads the first
sentence and the last sentence
this person and his brother invented the
fastest track vehicle they put it in GI
Geo they have government contracts this
guy is a full-on engineer works with all
Geniuses and for practical not
opinionated you know practical
Technologies
and he only reads the first sentence and
the last and what do you think my
response was same who do you think my
response is the same I'm going to
confess it guys I've never read a book
and people are making fun of Kanye I
find that so refreshing because I bet I
bet many if not most of the people
making fun of Kanye for not reading a
book
probably haven't read very many books
themselves and they probably don't read
regularly and they probably don't read
particularly probing important works
they just flatter themselves that
they're really really smart and educated
I'm so much smarter and educated than
Kanye West
maybe but probably not and and I know
that you're not wiser than Kanye West in
this regard
neither of you probably know very much
of anything and you think that you know
a whole lot and Kanye has the humility
to say yeah I'll be real guys I don't
really read books yeah I don't know you
know I just don't really
I'm gonna totally admit it he's he's
willing to look foolish for the sake of
honesty
which which actually is a sign of wisdom
it is a sign of wisdom to be able to say
yeah I don't really know very much about
that who knows and here's what I'll tell
you when I look at how Kanye's school is
set up what they're teaching there
looks like a way more serious
educational institution than pretty much
any public school in the country
and then most private schools too
here's what they say using an ethic of
integrity and Care donde Academy
prepares students to become the next
generation of leaders thinkers and
innovators by providing them with a
world-class education that includes the
rigorous Core Curriculum how many
schools are missing that that basic Core
Curriculum these days where you read
great works and you study the classic
subjects very few schools to still do
that and an emphasis on sustainability
creativity critical thinking and problem
solving
sounds great I love it I would I would
be much more inclined to send my kids to
Kanye West University than I would to to
virtually any other institution in the
country I love books I love reading
books I actually do read a lot of books
I host a show about books and I
encourage everyone else to read books
too
but even more than that I encourage
people to be very honest with themselves
and recognize the paucity of all of our
education okay and to recognize the
limits to our knowledge and to have some
curiosity and above all some humility
Socrates one of the smartest fellas ever
to walk the earth and here's the direct
quote I have it copied down here
although I do not suppose that either of
us knows anything really beautiful and
good I am better off than he is for he
knows nothing and thinks he knows I
neither know nor think I know speaking
of schools I I meant to announce this on
the show a while ago I'm glad I can
announce it now I will be speaking at
Wisconsin Lutheran College this Thursday
very excited to be there if you happen
to be in the Milwaukee area come on by
you can check out the information on
yaf.org it's going to be a ton of fun
some people have pointed out that it's
kind of funny that I'm kicking off my
school tour this year at Wisconsin
Lutheran University or Wisconsin
Lutheran College rather because I happen
to be a mackerel snapping papist
and I say it has to be that way because
now I get disinvited from the Catholic
schools last semester I was invited by
students at the University of St Thomas
St Thomas is my confirmation Saint okay
uh I this is obviously a very Catholic
University or at least it's supposed to
be and the students were not permitted
to follow through with their invitations
the school administration shut down my
invite
specifically because I espouse Catholic
views on transgenderism because I say
that men and women are different and Men
Can't become women and women can't
become men
pretty much reading straight out of the
catechism of the Catholic Church
the Catholic School
says I'm not allowed to come
but the Lutheran School will welcome me
okay so this is hey Catholics get your
act together okay especially nominally
Catholic universities that are really
only pretending to be Catholic their
true religion is leftism and whenever
their their purported faith in
Catholicism comes into conflict with
their true faith and leftism they're
going to give the edge to leftism so I'm
very excited to hang out with all the
lutherans up there in Wisconsin hope to
see you there as well
okay and maybe we'll be talking about
some of those those issues that got me
banned from the University of Saint
Thomas namely like basic facts about uh
human sex speaking of sexual impropriety
there's a clip that's gone viral
I have intentionally tried not to follow
the details of this too much because the
whole story is just absolute tabloid
trash and I don't want to Sully my mind
or Soul following too closely what's
going on but the the broad Strokes of it
are that some Tick Tock chick had an
affair with a rock star with the singer
from Maroon 5 who's married and has kids
and now she's making tick tocks to get
more attention talking about how she had
this affair
I was having an affair with a man who's
married to a Victoria's Secret model at
the time you know I was
young I was naive and I mean quite
frankly I feel exploited I wasn't in the
scene like I am now
um so I was definitely very easily
manipulated
Maroon 5 is practically elevator music
at this point so I'm sure you know who
Adam Levine is
um but Adam and I were seeing each other
for about a year
after I stopped talking to him over you
know a period of months this is uh how
he came back into my life
he said okay serious question I'm having
another baby and if it's a boy I really
uh want to name it Sumner you okay with
that dead serious
um
I was like
I'm in hell like I have to be in hell at
this point I mean my morals were
unknowingly compromised I was completely
manipulated
she was totally manipulated she's such a
victim she uh knowingly and willingly
had a year-long affair with a married
man a married man with multiple children
but she's just such a victim you know
don't you think she's such a victim
I don't actually I actually think she
should just sort of shut up and be quiet
about it
and apologize to the man's wife and
and stop pretending that this is all
about her the only victims here are this
man's wife and children those are the
victims okay and the man and the woman
did something very bad and I'm not just
here to shame them and and
moralize and wag my finger okay Drew
Clavin has a great point he says that
every man has two drinks and a wink away
from ruining his life okay I I have a
great Terror
of I'm I'm very glad that I haven't done
this I hope I never do this I have a
great Terror of I mean this is probably
the thing I fear the most could you
imagine betraying the people who you
love the most who are so close to you
it's awful there before the grace of God
goes all of us
but
if they do this terrible thing
apologize and and try to atone and keep
it to yourself but we can't do that in
our culture anymore anymore because the
only thing that we can do in our culture
is is claim to be the victim everything
has to be about us everything has to be
about seeking attention and somehow
everything is everyone else's fault
except for our own this is just the flip
side of that same Pride that Pride that
says I know everything and I'm such a
genius and you know I went I got three
degrees at Harvard and that's why little
boys are actually little girls and we
should chop off their genitals because
I'm so smart and these people look like
idiots the flip side of that is never
feeling any sense of shame or guilt if
you do because you can't do anything
wrong because you're so smart and great
right you you have to be the victim even
at the time you didn't think of yourself
as the victim even as you're explaining
it it's so implausible that you would be
the victim but you have to be the victim
because you're so you're perfect right
this girl in her mind she's just
absolutely perfect she can't do anything
wrong
that's the flip side of it too it's just
that I mean it makes sense sometimes we
talk about slavery is America's original
sin I don't think that's America's
original sin original sin is America's
original sin and pride which causes the
fall the queen of all vices that is just
absolute poison you see it in it
virtually every aspect of social
corruption
now
what one wants to do if one wants to
avoid these sorts of terrible things and
destroying one's life and family would
be to stay focused and some people can't
really stay focused speaking of focus
Joe Biden insists
that he is mentally very very focused
some people think that he's in decline
in senility and and you know gets lost
when a butterfly flies in front of his
face but no he says he is very very
focused just listen to him how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I mean it's just not uh
I haven't observed anything in terms of
there's not things I don't do now that I
did before whether it's physical or
mental or anything else
that's the polished edited version
that's the best version that 60 Minutes
could present of Joe Biden people say
people say I'm Sam and you can even say
it's kind of sad you can see it in how
vacant Joe Biden's eyes are he's kind of
got that that look to him that people
who are in sinality have and he said
people say I'm and I'm not and I'm folk
and I'm focused I could fly you know and
there are things that I
and I don't do things that I did that I
do things I never I don't there's
nothing I didn't do that I do
you know you know the thing really
really sad obviously
obviously not all with it this is why
the Democrats are all circling the
wagons to try to give themselves
positions
I was talking to Ted Cruz about this uh
last night
he said you know he sees this pretty
pretty up close and personal in DC
you said you could tell for six months
now Buddha judge and Kamala both want to
replace Biden when he obviously can't
run for president 2024. and they're
already starting to stab each other in
the back and go on TV as much as
possible
they're already trying to do it and when
you look at the dysfunction
of our system
it's it's tempting right now to look
around the world and say
is there any better sort of system and
this is an especially good time for that
because of the death of Queen Elizabeth
there's a ton of focus on the British
form of government specifically on the
monarchical aspect of the British form
of government and all these rituals and
there are some people in America
and in Great Britain but especially in
America who are making fun of all the
rituals who think this is why on Earth
is some random family just giving all
this money and all this Prestige and
they're looked up to and all this Pomp
and Circumstance and the guys wearing
the funny tall hats standing guard
around it's just like totally crazy we
would never do that kind of crazy thing
in America you saw there were these
beautiful ceremonies before Queen
Elizabeth was laid to rest yesterday
there were these wonderful vigils where
her son the king
and his siblings would stand vigil
around the casket not like someone was
going to come vandalize it anyway and
not like Prince Charles now King Charles
was going to do anything about it in
particular but they just stand there and
there's a ritual and this ritual has
gone on for hundreds and hundreds of
years the Americans look at that
especially the liberal kind of Americans
they say who needs all that stupid
ritual
what they don't realize is that we have
it too I was thinking back to Ruth Bader
ginsburg's lying in state Ruth Bader
Ginsburg lies in state
and where was it was it in the U.S
Capitol I don't know some you know big
fancy government building in DC and
she's there and the the coffin is draped
in the American flag and there are
people standing vigil and standing guard
and then at one point as people are
coming to pay their respects to the
coffin ginsburg's personal trainer walks
up and starts doing push-ups in front of
the coffin as a kind of Final Act of
loyalty and respect to Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and this happened for days and
days and days we're doing the exact same
thing that the British do with their
monarchy the only difference is that
we're doing it in a less dignified way
for people who are much less deserving
of it the queen gave her entire life to
service of the crown and suppressed her
own desires and interests all along the
way and suffered all sorts of
indignities and yes she had a palace and
yes she had servants and yes she had a
bunch of money but money actually
doesn't buy happiness she didn't have
the freedom of choice to do pretty much
anything she wanted her whole life was
about Duty and she did it in a very
dignified way because she recognized
that there are obligations in society
and traditions that must be maintained
and she remained that symbol of unity
for Great Britain in a period of massive
social upheaval when a lots of other
societies did not fare nearly as well as
Britain did
and she did it and now people are paying
formal respect to her as they lay her to
rest we do all that same stuff here in
America we just pretend that we don't
and it's all kind of weird and kooky and
it's for people who are not deserving of
one one thousandth this sort of respect
that Queen Elizabeth was because you
can't escape this stuff much as we want
to pretend that we're sort of radical
modernist rationalists Republican people
who are all done with the crazy myths
and Pomp and Circumstance of of the old
monarchies were not because man is an
incarnate being and an essentially
religious being and we're liturgical and
we're ritualistic and we need all of
these sorts of things and we must have
in society things that are held sacred
and we must have shared religious and
moral beliefs and we much must have a
shared standards and when we get rid of
the old ones the good ideas of virtue
and Duty and Christianity when we get
rid of all of that it's not like we just
are left with nothing and it's an it's
an empty vacuum what we what comes in is
a bunch of insane new ideas to fill that
space like transgenderism and a kind of
cult of personal autonomy and abortion
happy robed lawyers
that are treated in the same way as a
British monarch
it's absolutely it's undeniable and so
the question is not how do we get rid of
all these crazy old rituals the question
is what should the rituals be what do
what do we Revere what do we venerate
what do we hold sacred
and and if we are going to have people
who are revered in this country should
they be these tawdry Petty politicians
or should they have some dignity in some
class
speaking of petty politicians there's a
scandal brewing in New York and because
New York is fairly corrupt no one's even
really paying attention to it but the
chief of staff for the mayor of New York
Eric Adams the chief of staff was caught
using taxpayer dollars to take a cruise
in France and it was obviously a
personal vacation but this guy pretended
that he was out there doing research
doing research you know in the French
Riviera who knows what kind of research
this uh bureaucrat from New York City
was conducting out there but that mayor
Adams was asked about this he just
brushes It Off
the times reported that your Chief of
Staff spent time on a cruise ship in
France for research purposes I wanted to
see what he was trying to figure out
there and let that taxpayer funded you
see what I go through
[Laughter]
I answered a cruise ship question
already I'm not going back and forth on
that when there's something when there's
something to announce more about a
cruise ship
um idea or any other idea I'm gonna
announce it I'm finished with that next
question I'm finished you got to see
what I have to deal with over here man I
got to deal with occasionally a reporter
asked me a real question it's ridiculous
man come on man I got to deal with it
why you tell them just because my chief
of staff embezzled taxpayer dollars to
go on a fancy vacation in France now I
gotta answer that question no I mean I'm
not going to answer that question you
crazy that's absolutely crazy moving on
don't you dare ask me that question
again and then the crazy part is they
just move on
because we are increasingly used to this
kind of corruption we laugh about it I
was laughing about it at the top of the
show because we're so used to it now
oh yeah well DeSantis is looking pretty
hot for 2024 I guess they're going to
put him under criminal investigation and
you know that's just what happens now
you know you know our alleged sacred
democracy which is really just kind of a
one-party oligarchy where the president
of the United States says that if you
even think about voting for the other
party you're a terrorist and an
extremist and a threat to democracy and
a Nazi and a fascist well yeah what
happens is if you're ever going to pose
any threat to the ruling regime then
they're going to investigate you and try
to throw you into prison okay moving on
moving on
it's kind of sad
it actually it kind of kind of brings me
down a notch as an American
because Americans we're really proud of
our country America's done lots of great
things it's founded on really some
really wonderful ideas
and
I think all Americans now and the polls
reflect this feel that we're in a period
of national decline in a kind of
national malaise and we've lost
something
of which we used to be really really
proud
and we've turned what was I think a
healthy love of our country and a love
of virtue and the good into a just a
kind of shallow Pride for being
Americans that we're so much better than
everybody else well I don't know I mean
if you look at the way that our
government is conducted right now
I I don't know that we have a big
soapbox and and a a lot of credibility
to to lecture and scold the world
because we're we're certainly not living
up
to the best of what our nation could be
we've got to look to ourselves as long
as we're just here out bragging we're
just so wonderful we've got 10 degrees
from Harvard and Stanford and we're
going to make ourselves dumb okay we're
we're already giving away so much Social
cohesion our political Traditions our
highest ideals our understanding of
basic facts about the difference between
boys and girls we've given that up
because of our stupid bride maybe a
little humility will will help us get to
a more of a national renewal the rest of
the show is continuing now we've got
David Cohn coming on that's right that's
right one of three heads of crane and
Company because he and I are going head
to head in fantasy football and you know
me I'm a football Mogul I'm a sports
Maven my friends we've got it we've got
a very serious uh discussion to be had
about this this Liberty University
UMass gay football team from someone who
actually knows about football if you're
not a member click the link in the
description and join us we'll see you
over on the member block
[Music]
[Music]
laughs